s'il vous plaît l'empiré du small talk
là tout le monde sera content d'être ce
qu'on sait déjà allégé c'est de sauver
vos postes s'il vous plaît vas-y ok
merci aux mâles dominants pour la petite
humiliation publique
merci rejet bon je sais que la fusion a
généré un petit peu des dissensions sur
et c'est pour ça que je vous réunis tous
ensemble
aujourd'hui c'est pour extérioriser ses
tensions et veut partir sur de bonnes
bases
d'accord alors qu'est ce que j'ai écrit
sur le tableau des team building
exactement merci m c'est un vertical en
graphiques team building t comme
transparence eux comme écoute élégance
élégance écoute plutôt à on va vraiment
faire toutes les lettres l'apa sont soit
anciens on se dit les choses
c'est superbe c'est qu'on va faire un
petit jeu voilà le tia koné levez vous
tous
allez tout le monde se lève allez-y
alors restez assis en fait rester assis
jeu désolé pour la porte on va tous
avoué chacun notre tour un petit secret
d'un truc qu'on a fait au bureau mais
qu'on n'a jamais dit à personne
ça va nous libérer d'accord wen à toi tu
commences
ben moi j'ai déjà volé une agrafeuse
attends attends ça ferait que cherche
une agrafeuse good sochaux si je pouvais
me lève je ne vois pas les agrafes des
handicapés ça va pas la tête à des
handicapés ont dit des handicapés déjà
des gens oui non allez hop salsa pleine
rue c'est pas bien voilà c'est pas bien
mais c'est bien de le dire merci à toi
ma mine moi je voulais une ramette de
papier
d'accord c'est oui donc c'est la même
chose tu as volé quelque chose c'est
pareil qui ici a volé des trucs quand
même d'accord quoi bon très bien voilà
savez quoi
voilà c'est uniquement quand vous avez
la graffeuse de parole dans la main que
vous pouvez parler c'est clair vous
voyez le tas de crottes de nez sur le
mur des toilettes mais c'est moi en même
temps si les toilettes vous voulez que
j'aimais tout l'attaquant les bouffées
marinaro même au delà des agrafeuses de
parole on a dit agrafeuse de parole
marina etc et merci d'être livrés tu
peux passer la coiffeuse à roule
en fauteuil roulant fauteuil roulant je
l'appelle tout le temps fauteuil roulant
poussé par son prénom
j'ai passé la grèce alors moi et parfois
et je prends mon doigt veux me mets dans
mon nombril et je le sens et ça pue
des gens ça pue n'est qu'à mais ça c'est
parce que tu es handicapés ou pas non
non non c'est tout le monde normalement
pu dû essayer à temps vous prenez votre
doigt vous tournez tournez dedans
tourner et vous le sentez sans nom a
quand même je te dis sans aller du
handicap était un peu obligé il ya
quelqu'un dans cette pièce qui pue de la
gueule non écoute partie le jeu c'est de
dire quelque chose sur toi ok des fois
ya quelque chose qui me dérange il ya
quelqu'un dans cette pièce qui pue de la
gueule mais va te faire
c'est marrant tu te sens visé pour peter
mashona je suis désolé mais mais mais ça
elle s'attache pas mais ça mais ma main
dans ta gueule l étalage de toute sa
classe
alice alors moi j'ai couché avec
quelqu'un de bien mais c'est kim sa
takka takka takka takka takka takka non
non mais le drh chez moi arrêtez de dire
n'importe quoi se rendit donc c'est le
derrière sinon que c'est pas lui
c'est un cauchemar sont mon rythme vas-y
hockey tout ça c'est que du positif
d'accord maintenant l'essentiel c'est
d'être un groupe fort et apaiser et à
baiser aussi parce que ma voix tout ce
qu'elle verrait aimons penser que dire
des conneries voilà le seul tu qu'il
fallait pas dire qu'un plan social il ya
un plan social
non non non polaris diagonale on se
donne la main enfin si on s'entend mieux
là bas c'est comme ça
[Musique]